good evening john yeah i'll tell you
what it was a real wild game here 93 475
fans packing a t stadium something
really cool happened prior to the game
they had a horn play a a horn guy play
the national anthem but the entire
stadium was singing the national anthem
very emotional time here at atnt stadium
a lot of people loving that and singing
really loud it was pretty cool to hear
that but as you mentioned this was a
wild wild game there were 28 flags
thrown in this game
276 yards in penalties the cowboys were
flagged for 166 yards the raiders 110
yards it was crazy and how ironic is
this the game-winning field goal was led
by a penalty on the cowboys so it was a
wild wild game daniel carlson the kicker
five for five on field goals after
obviously all smiles for the character
this is what he had to say
it's a competitive league i mean that's
that's the way it's supposed to be it's
supposed to be close games you know back
and forth all the time so um you know i
i just know our team i think it speaks a
lot to our character you know to come on
a short week after you know facing quite
a bit of adversity the last few months a
few weeks
and you know to play a game like we did
winning it over time that's a big
testament to our team's character
i'll tell you what there's been a lot of
games played on thanksgiving day this
has to be one of the more exciting games
the
raiders snapped that three-game losing
streak they are now six and five on the
season and they wait next week for the
redskins to roll into las vegas so i
have much more for you coming up a
little bit later reporting live from
inside a t stadium i'm chris matthews we
are live local now